y la invasión de rusia a ucrania ha
recibido la condena general de los
miembros de la otan la alianza militar
de 30 naciones ha subrayado que se
mantendrá al margen del conflicto y no
pondrá sus gotas sobre el terreno en
ucrania en cambio proporcionará armas y
apoyo a kiev
los aliados de la otan continúan
apoyando a ucrania
y de hecho en la reunión de hoy con la
unión europea- finlandia y suecia los
aliados anunciaron e informaron a los
aliados sobre el tipo de armas y el tipo
de apoyo que también incluye sistemas de
defensa aérea
systems como ucranianos miembro de la
otan no está cubierta por el artículo 5
la regla que obliga a la alianza militar
a defender a cualquier estado miembro en
caso de ataque sin embargo la alianza
está enviando más tropas de su fuerza de
respuesta a los países miembros de
europa del este en el marco de los
planes de defensa activados el jueves
uy
cifras tenemos una presencia defensiva
en el este que estamos aumentando
nuestra presencia no para provocar un
conflicto sino para prevenir uno y que
no haya dudas sobre la disposición de la
otan para proteger y defender a todos
los aliados nuestro compromiso y la
tarea central de la otan es con nuestro
lema uno para todos y todos para uno un
ataque contra un aliado se considerará
un ataque contra torio nada
como hasta ahora el ataque de rusia se
ha limitado a ucrania pero varios países
cercanos de la otan como estonia letonia
lituania y polonia están en alerta
máxima y han pedido formalmente
consultas bajo el artículo 4 de la otan
que los aliados pueden invocar cuando la
integridad territorial la independencia
política o la seguridad de cualquiera de
sus miembros se vea amenazada